a poll out today by the chartered
management institute and shared with
this program has found that trust in the
uk
government to support the growth of the
economy has fallen
from 2 in december 2020 to
minus 13 now that means the majority of
managers
do not trust the government to support
growth there is a particular drop in
london
with trust falling from minus 20 in
december to minus 31
now amongst businesses and
that's pretty worrying especially among
small and medium-sized firms with trust
amongst managers in those businesses
falling nine points between the end of
last year and the start of this
well let's talk to the chief executive
of the group that ran that survey and
frank good to see you
this morning why do you think that
confidence has dropped so significantly
well the overall reason is the
government's handling of the pandemic
and it isn't just the economic handling
it's the overall handling and
in fact three quarters of our survey
respondents cited that
as their main driver um now
if you dig into that we've heard on on
this program some of the
things that people have been pointing
out that businesses have been pointing
out
the lack of clarity um the lack of clear
communication
consistent communication and the need
for a comprehensive
plan that addresses just exactly how
we're going to come out of this pandemic
what is the road to recovery that is
actually
includes all sectors of the economy and
is targeted
and recognizes those sectors such as uh
travel
and hospitality that have been hardest
hit
so i would say that those are the main
reasons driving this drop
how problematic would it be though if if
government came out with with a timed
recovery plan
and then those timings were broken
because the situation wasn't improving
as it should be would that prove
problematic for businesses because it'd
be built up to something that then
didn't happen
so what we know about good management is
that you do admit uncertainties
and you also acknowledge that these can
change
and what what i think is appreciated is
when you have a clarity
of a decision so for example here's what
we're going to do
if it's x and if it's y here's what
we're going to do then
so you're laying out different scenarios
and that's quite
important and what has been happening is
a lot of sort of last minute decision
making for example the brexit agreement
which you know
there was no clarity until uh that the
day of
the 30th of december right so it's it's
that last minute decision making that
needs to improve
just how i mean is it possible to assess
at this stage just how much damage is
being done
to the economy by what we've seen over
the past 12 months
well we do know that obviously we're
having mass unemployment
uh we do know that people are having
major underlying financial issues
uh we also know that there are major
mental health issues
we are disrupting young people's
schooling so the impacts the fallout of
this pandemic is
absolutely dire and it affects everybody
so that's all the more reason to have a
very inclusive
plan and i would say as part of the
rebuilding efforts
we need to make sure that we put
managerial skills like
clarity of communication at the heart of
that rebuilt it isn't enough
only to have the technical skills we
need to have people skills
listening skills to build out of this
pandemic
now we can and the vaccination program
is an excellent example of something
that is well planned and is being well
executed
we need more well-executed endeavors to
come out of this pandemic
in a stronger position i mean how how
much danger are we in that in terms of
a recovery i mean there was all this
talk initially of a sort of v-shaped
recovery that's what people were talking
about i mean clearly we've gone into
i don't know more of a w or something at
the moment but i mean
do you have confidence that whenever we
do get out of this
that that the economy can actually
bounce back or
are we going past the point of no return
well
obviously people are talking about a
double-dip recession and you know it's
very unfortunate britain is
um is among the worst hit
economically in this crisis and also
among the worst hit in health terms and
in death rate terms so
we have a lot riding on this recovery
and i would say
that we can recover but it's all the
more important that we
actually take our recovery efforts
seriously we have to engage as many
people as possible in that recovery
because being inclusive uh as we were
for example when we rebuilt this country
after the second world war having those
inclusive efforts
is absolutely vital to making a success
of it and that means it has to be
incredibly well managed